ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITOpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TADGE DRYJA: So today
I'm going to talk about
MAST, taproot, and graftroot.
And these are pretty cool
new ideas in Bitcoin.
They're not really
production ready.
They're still sort
of ideas, but it's
kind of neat to look at the
future directions of how
people are thinking about
improving these protocols.
So we're going to talk
about new types of scripts--
MAST, taproot, and graftroot--
and all those sort
of interactions
between these three things.
I will define these, of course.
So so far we've
talked about scripts.
And you've got up codes.
You've got a stack.
I think with the homework
people sort of got the idea,
OK, I can do OP_RETURN.
I can do OP_CHECKSIG, and the
basic idea of how it works.
So right now in Bitcoin, it's
mostly pay to pubkey hash.
So most of the scripts
that you'll see-- mostly,
output scripts in an
output look like this.
OP_DUP, OP_HASH160, thumb
pubkey hash OP_EQUALVERIFY,
OP_CHECKSIG.
And then when you want
to execute the script,
you put a pubkey and a
signature as your input.
It duplicates the pubkey, hashes
it, pushes this hash onto it,
checks that those
two things are equal.
And this also removes
those two things,
leaving only the signature,
and then checks the signature.
So if they're not
equal-- if you try
to sign with a different
pubkey than the one that
is committed to in this pubkey
hash, it'll fail at this point.
And if you put the right
pubkey but the wrong signature,
it'll fail at this point.
Well, it'll the CHECKSIG will
fail, put a 0 on the stack.
And then the stack will have
a 0 on it, and that'll fail.
Verify means, immediately fail,
if these things are not equal.
And then in segwit,
they templated it.
So really, this entire script
became OP_0, pubkey hash,
which is confusing.
If you don't know
what that means--
wait, OP_0 means just
put a 0 on the stack,
and then put a pubkey
hash on the stack,
and anyone can spend this.
But the idea in segwit
is, yes, software
that is not aware of segwit
will see this as spendable
by anyone without a signature.
Software that is aware of segwit
knows that these two things
are the same.
So essentially, if you see
this, turn it into this.
Take the pubkey hash and
fill in these OP codes.
And that's actually
what the code does,
for the script interpreter.
It will say, oh, it
matches this template.
It's OP_0 and a
20-byte piece of data.
Turn it into this,
and then execute it.
So in this way, segwit
saves three bytes.
Because now you have one byte
there instead of 1, 2, 3, 4.
You lose a couple more
bytes elsewhere in segwit,
so it actually tends to
lose a couple of bytes.
But whatever.
So this works.
This makes sense.
Any questions about
pay to pubkey hash?
It works OK?
And there's also
pay to script hash.
This is the other thing you'll
see quite a bit of in Bitcoin
today.
I don't know what
the ratios are.
80% pay to pubkey hash,
20% pay to script hash--
something like that.
So a minority, but significant.
And for pay to script
hash, it looks like this--
also sort of template-y, right?
OP_HASH160, a script
hash, OP_EQUAL.
That's it.
This also seems like,
wait, all I have to do
is provide a pre-image
of this, and then I'll
be able to spend the coins.
But the script
interpreter knows-- no,
actually what this means--
if you see this template,
if you see this format--
verify that this
is equal, and then
execute whatever the
pre-image was, as a script.
So actually the first
time I started programming
Bitcoin stuff, I did not know
about pay to script hash,
and I was just trying to
make my own transactions.
And I used this.
I just said, well, I want to
see that I can get the script
to execute right.
I'll just take a
random number, hash it,
put it into this thing,
and try to spend it.
And it never worked,
and I didn't know why.
And then a few days later, I
read about pay to script hash.
Wait, it wasn't days later.
I just put an OP.
I put an OP, no OP, OP_HASH160,
script hash, OP_EQUAL.
And then it worked.
And I was like, OK, I don't
know how Bitcoin works.
This doesn't make any sense.
I put a no OP, and
then it starts working.
And then a few days later I
read about pay to script hash,
and it was, oh, this actually
has a special meaning.
This is a template where if
you HASH160, a bunch of data,
and OP_EQUAL, then it interprets
the pre-image as a script.
Does it have to be
20 bytes, probably?
Yeah, I don't know.
There's actually a
vulnerability here.
How pay to script
hash got introduced
is sort of an
interesting debate.
There was OP_EVAL,
pay to script hash--
a bunch of argument about it.
And this was in 2012,
I think, or '11.
And it was sort of contentious,
and people argue about it.
And in retrospect this
is actually insecure
because you're using
OP_HASH160 160,
which is 160-byte hash function.
It's basically SHA-256
followed by RIPEMD-160.
This is not big enough.
You're committing to a script
hash, which is 20 bytes.
So normally you're like, yeah,
whatever, 160 bits is plenty.
You can have collision
attacks, where
if you're doing multisig
with someone else,
they may be able to calculate
different pubkeys, so
that your pubkey--
they have a collision where
two different 20-byte scripts
hash to the same thing.
Sorry, two different scripts,
hashed to the same 20 bytes.
This is possible
because that's only 2
to the 80 work which
is still a lot.
And used to be considered
like, no one can do--
2 to the 80 is beyond
any human endeavor.
But Bitcoin does 2 to the
80 work every day, hour.
I don't know, something
fairly reasonable.
So it's like, wait, 2
to the 80 is not enough.
For the same security as
Bitcoin, which is generally a 2
to the 128 security
parameter, we
would need this to be
256 bits instead of 160.
So when they upgraded the segwit
pay to witness script hash,
this has to be 32
bytes, to eliminate
any of those collision
vulnerabilities.
So yeah, that's what
distinguishes it.
So they look the same,
Right it's just OP_0,
piece of data,
OP_0, piece of data.
But they do completely
different things
based on how long this data is.
OK, so that's pay
to script hash.
Any questions about
the basic construction?
OK, I want to make it so
that two of these three keys
must sign, in order
to spend the coins.
So I say, OP_2 push three public
keys OP_3, OP_CHECKMULTISIG.
So the idea is two of
these three must sign.
So you can put OP_1, this OP_3.
You can OP_3-- this OP_3.
If you put OP_4, three
keys, and then OP_3,
it probably will never be
spendable and just never work.
I'm pretty sure you have
to put the signatures
in the correct order.
So when you spend, you
say, OP_0, sigA, sigC.
And that's A, C. If you
put sigC, sigA, it fails.
This is a fun little part, where
you have to put in a 0 byte
before the signatures,
when you want to spend.
I'm not 100% sure
how that got in.
It was a screw up, and we
just live with it forever.
[LAUGHS] If you don't put
the OP_0, it doesn't work.
And it's somewhat confusing.
It wastes a byte, which
is not a huge deal.
But it's just like, what?
And they didn't
fix that in segwit.
It just stays in there.
Who knows if it'll ever get out.
So segwit was an
opportunity to fix it.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Why didn't they just
update that pretty quickly
when they realized you
have to put an OP_0 there?
TADGE DRYJA: Hard fork.
So you put this in.
And you could say,
wait, that's stupid.
Wait, you need a 0 in front
when you put the signatures?
Let's get rid of that.
So now the old software
says, no, I need a 0 here.
And then if you don't put the
0, and you just put the two
signatures, I fail this script.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't have
to be a 0 until the [INAUDIBLE]?
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
It could be anything.
It could just be any data.
And it was like any data the
stack would get popped off.
And then the two signatures.
So if you said, let's
eliminate that requirement that
would actually be a
hard fork, because it
would be allowing scripts that
were previously invalid to now
become valid.
And that's a huge undertaking,
that has sort of only
happened once in Bitcoin,
and that wasn't even planned.
And so it's just like,
whatever, leave it.
They did soft fork it then.
Is it soft forked or policy?
AUDIENCE: Soft fork.
TADGE DRYJA: So they
did soft fork and say,
it needs to be a 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, I'm not sure.
So it could be non-standard, or
it could be an actual consensus
rule, that that has to be a 0.
It used to be anything,
and now it should be a 0.
Put a 0 and then it'll work.
But that remains in segwit
as well, with multisig.
They could have fixed it.
They didn't want to touch it.
It was just like, whatever.
When you see one of these,
turn it into one of these,
and just do the exact same
thing you used to be doing.
That's a lot simpler and easier.
So kind of weird,
but this works.
People use this a lot,
especially exchanges.
Exchanges very often use
this kind of construction,
because it helps
people manage keys.
If one key gets compromised,
you don't lose all your money.
Usually, 2 of 3,
sometimes 3 of 4.
3 of 3, 2 of 2--
all sorts of constructions
where this is extremely useful.
And actually, I'll be talking
about more powerful signature
aggregation and
multisig on Wednesday.
But for now, this
is what we use.
And, how can we
make this better?
So one interesting thing--
pay to pubkey,
which is not really
used anymore, but used to
be used more frequently,
like in the early days.
If you look at
transactions in 2009, 2010,
this is predominant, I think.
And all the mining outputs
from a long time ago looked
like this.
And the output script
was just pubkey,
OP_CHECKSIG, which
is really simple.
And then the idea
is when you want
to spend it, you just push
a signature onto the stack.
Then you have signature,
pubkey, OP_CHECKSIG.
That's it.
It's really simple, and
it actually saves space.
Your pubkey is 33 bytes,
whereas your pubkey hash script,
the pubkey hash is 20 bytes.
So yeah, the pubkey
hash is 12 bytes smaller
plus the extra OP codes makes it
10 bytes savings for the output
script.
However, when you spend
with data pubkey hash,
you need to put the pubkey
itself and the signature.
So you're putting the pubkey
into the network either way,
eventually.
So this is actually overall
more space efficient,
in that you're saving 23 bytes
over the lifecycle of it.
The output is a
little bit bigger
but the input is significantly
smaller, so you end up saving.
Why do we always use pubkey
hashes instead of pubkeys?
There's a lot of
different opinions on it.
You know, it's Bitcoin,
there's no "answer."
People have different ideas
of why these are better.
Any ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] put
their pubkey out in public
before it got spent.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, that's
probably the predominant one.
And that's going
to be a tricky one
to try to convince
people is not the case.
I'll get to that.
But people started
arguing about pubkey hash.
When someone posted
about graftroot,
the discussion
devolved into a, wait,
I don't want my
pubkey on the network.
And there's some arguments
why you'd want a pubkey hash,
and it's more secure, but
there's a lot of arguments
that it doesn't actually
provide any extra security.
So that's a tricky one.
But that is one.
That is probably a
big one people like.
Other ideas why you
use pubkey hashes
instead of pubkeys themselves?
Size-- you want the
outputs to be small.
Also, I'm pretty sure when
Satoshi wrote all this,
he did not know about
compressed public keys,
because that stuff was
not in there for a while.
I think I mentioned this before.
Did I mention compressed
versus uncompressed pubkeys?
Yeah, probably.
OK, so review.
The idea is you've
got this whole curve
kind of deal, kind of thing--
usually like that.
Your public key is a
point on the curve.
You need an x and y-coordinate
to represent the point.
However, because
it's symmetric, you
can just say, well, I'll
tell you the x-coordinate.
You know, x equals 7.
I'm not going to tell
you the y-coordinate.
I'll just say y equals plus.
So go up, or go down.
That way, I can do 32
bytes for this and 1 bit
for that, at the
cost of a little bit
of extra computation.
So I can say, maybe y is
actually 5, or something.
So if I say, x equals 7,
y equals 5, that's quick
but it takes more space.
If I say x equals
7, y equals plus,
I now have to compute
what y is when
I see this-- which is pretty
quick, but take some time.
But it's a good tradeoff.
Anyway, I don't think Satoshi
knew about this idea--
or maybe thought of
it, never put it in.
So the public keys
were actually 65 bytes.
You want to keep
the output small,
because they're
in the UTF subset.
They're in the database.
And you need to be able
to think through this
and read it randomly.
Like, you don't know when
it's going to get spent.
You don't know what transaction
is going to query this.
So this has to go in an actual
database, key value store
kind of thing.
The signatures don't have
to be in any database.
They're just in
these old blocks,
and you read from them linearly.
You basically read through
the whole block at a time.
And high latency is fine.
There's never any
timing-critical reads for this.
So basically, you
could store the blocks
as just files on
your hard drive.
Block 1 dot dat, or
whatever-- block 2 dot dat--
and have 500,000 files, because
you basically always read them
a block at a time.
And you only have
to read them when
other people are doing IBD--
initialization block download--
and you're serving it to them.
So you can prune these, if you
run Bitcoin core with pruning.
Anyway, so the main idea
is, OK, even if it overall
increases the size
of transactions,
it does reduce the
size of the outputs--
which is the thing we
really want to minimize,
for keeping the speed up.
Questions about that?
Cool?
OK.
So similarly, same thing with
pay to pubkey hashes versus pay
to pubkey.
Instead of pay to script hash,
you could put the whole script
in an output--
like a multiset.
You could just have
all three of your keys
in your output script.
And that would
save space overall.
Your output is 20
bytes, and then
you reveal your whole
100-byte script,
so you save those 20 bytes.
Same amount, but
proportionately less, sorry.
It is some space
savings overall,
but it's better to keep
the output size small.
[INAUDIBLE] If you do this,
does it actually work?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: OK,
it's not standard,
so it might not propagate.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: I wouldn't
recommend this.
It probably will
not really work.
Maybe eventually it
will get confirmed,
if you find people to
confirm it for you,
but most nodes will ignore
these kinds of things.
OK, so the question for today--
what if we want really,
really big scripts?
So 2 of 3 multisig is cool.
We can just show all three keys.
And there's 33 bytes of data
that don't really get used.
If you're signing
with 2 of the 3 keys,
well, that means one of
the keys never got used.
It was sort of
there and pointless.
But whatever, it's 33 bytes.
So what if you want to do,
like, 2 of 50 multisig?
So here's 50 different keys.
Any two of these
people can sign.
Maybe you're in a company.
There's 50 employees.
And the policy is that,
OK, any of these two people
can use the coins for this
spending to buy lunch,
or whatever.
So how would you
2 of 250 multisig?
Any ideas?
You commit, and only reveal
part of a commitment.
So the cause of and solution to
all of blockchain's problems--
Merkle trees.
That's sort of the
solution for all--
throw a Merkle tree
on it, which is
sort of actually what
I'm working on now,
for another thing.
So you commit to
some kind of root,
and then you reveal only part
of what you've committed to.
So the idea, which is from--
there's debate about who
came up with this stuff--
MAST.
Like Peter [? Wohl ?]
was into it,
but then someone else said
they wrote a paper about it.
I don't know.
It was like 2013, 2014.
The original idea was make
a merkelized abstract syntax
tree.
So if you have done any
programming language courses,
you probably recognize the term
abstract syntax tree asked,
which is sort of
how compilers work.
They make this tree.
So the idea is, OK, we'll
make every node in that tree
like a Merkle root, so
every single OP code can
be revealed and be swapped out.
And it's super crazy.
That's sort of overkill.
So that was part of the
initial idea and paper.
But a much simpler
way to reason about it
and program it would
just be something like,
pay to script Merkle root.
Where in my output
script I have a root,
and then I reveal that
there is a script that
goes into that root, and
then execute that script.
So for example, I make
four different scripts.
So this would be--
anyway, it's just four
different scripts.
There's an O-2 choose
n, that results in four.
I don't think so.
But you know, this
is Alice and Bob.
This is Bob and Carol.
This is Carol and Dave.
This is Dave and
Edna, or something.
And any of these two people,
but four different groups,
can sign.
And then this is
what you actually
put in your output script.
And then when you
want to spend, you
say, OK, I'm going
to provide a proof.
So to spend, reveal
which I'm spending.
So for example, I'm
spending using script 3.
And then I reveal
a path to the root,
which would be I reveal 4, and
this, and then you compute.
You say, OK, hash these two
things together, you get that.
Hash of these two things
together, you get that.
And confirm that the
result is equal to what
was in the output script.
And if it is, OK, you've
provided a valid inclusion
proof that script 3
was inside this root.
What's kind of
cool-- in this case,
you do not need the
binary tree to be perfect.
You can have different
heights, because you're not
committing to the height of the
tree when you're sending to it.
So the default
case could be here,
and then a really big tree
that goes down a lot over here.
So in most cases it's going
to be Alice and Bob signing.
And then Carol and Dave,
and Edna and whatever,
are unlikely.
So I'm going to put Alice
and Bob here, and then
have the tree sort
of asymmetrically
get longer over here.
So that when Alice and Bob
sign, they can just reveal this.
And then when the
other people sign,
they're going to have
to reveal this and this.
And then I optimize my space
for the most likely case.
So that's kind of cool.
What else?
However, there are
a bunch of problems.
One, OK, 2 of 50 is cool.
So in the case of 250,
let's just look through it.
50 choose 2-- I couldn't
make the little numbers
in parentheses the right--
whatever.
So that's 1,225
different scripts.
And if you do a
regular binary tree--
balanced-- I forget
all the words--
you get a tree height of 11.
Which is kind of like,
oh, it's so close, right?
If it was 1,024, it'd be
10, but a little over.
And actually, since it
doesn't have to be symmetric,
you can get like tree
height 10 for most leaves,
and then 11 for some of them.
Anyway, so your
proof size is going
to be 352 bytes, which is OK.
And if you didn't use
MAST, you can say, well,
I'm just going to have
a pay to script hash.
And this script is just
going to show all 50 keys,
and have OP_2,
all 50 keys, OP_3.
And that would be about plus 3,
or something, but 1,650 bytes.
So MAST is an improvement.
And it's sort of like,
hey, I'm doing log n.
And for all the different
scripts, I have log n.
If I actually committed
to all the 1,225 scripts
with each of the two
keys, it'd be much bigger.
But I don't actually
have to, because I've got
this whole 50 choose 2 in here.
So I've got two things.
I've got this combinatorial
thing, and then this log thing.
And in balance, it's like,
OK, meh-- like, better,
but not actually that awesome.
You're going from
1.6k to 350 bytes.
It gets worse.
Let's say I want to do 25 of 50.
Well, that's 50 choose 25,
which is around 100 trillion
different combinations.
The tree height would now be 47.
The proof size is going to be--
wait, did I do that wrong?
Hold on.
47 by 32 is 1,504.
OK, sorry, for some
reason I have 22 there.
Sorry, I'll fix that.
But that is correct.
Yeah, 1,504.
So 1.5k, whereas the raw
would still be 1,650.
These are about the same.
This is not a great
space savings.
Your proofs are huge.
In fact, I would say it's
not only not much better,
it's worse.
You're going to have to compute
200 trillion hashes in order
to compute that root, as the
person creating the output
script.
To verify inclusion,
you have to compute
47 hashes, which is fine.
200 trillion hashes
is doable, but that's
going to take a while.
And that's annoying.
How long?
Hours, days?
I don't know.
Doable, but not fun.
So MAST doesn't really
get you necessarily
what you want here, although
this is kind of a silly case.
None of the things
really get you
what you want here,
because of these sort
of combinatorial problems.
Any questions, or oppositions
if I have screwed up
some math somewhere?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: So
compare these two.
If I show a tree height of
10 or 11, huh, that's weird.
There's like 1,000 different
scripts around in this tree.
If I show a tree height of
47, that's really weird.
Someone either was
just joking around
and made this weird sparse
tree with all these branches
to just screw around
and have a height of 47,
or there's 200 trillion
possible spending outcomes.
So it reveals information about
the things that were not spent.
Even though it doesn't
reveal what the scripts were,
it to some extent reveals
how many there were.
But still it is kind
of useful, right?
In the 2 of 50 case,
yes, this is better.
You have to compute a
thousand-something hashes.
No big deal.
You reduce your size
from 1.6k to 353 bytes.
That's a good deal.
Here kind of not, but this
is also sort of a crazy--
there's other ways to address
this, but it's pretty good.
There's sort of two, or
more than two different ways
to implement this.
You could just say,
OK, we're going
to have pay to
script Merkle root,
where you have a
template-- where
it's like OP_2, or OP_3, or
something, and then some data.
And the idea is
when you spend it,
you have to provide a proof,
and then the script itself.
And then, you
execute the script.
Another way which is
kind of cool-- and people
were talking about
it recently-- you
have this tail call
recursion-looking thing.
Where the idea is, if
you evaluate your script
and then there's two items
left on the stack at the end,
what you say is, OK--
whichever is bottom or top--
one of these items, the
bottom one, is a Merkle root.
And then the other
item on the stack
is the proof and arguments--
another script.
So you can sort of
recursively say, OK, well, I
went down into this
script with this proof
and then executed it.
And then things were
left on the stack,
and it was another proof,
for another Merkle root.
So that's kind of cool.
You can make all sorts of
crazy things with that.
I don't know how useful
recursion is in this case,
but there could be cases.
You're already in a binary tree.
So my personal thing is,
why not just keep it simple
and pay to a script Merkle root?
But there's people
who think, no, this
should be more expressive, like
programming language-y wise.
Anyway, so that's
the state of MAST.
MAST has code.
There's a pull
request in bip, right?
Yeah.
So there's some people
who are really into MAST.
And like, let's get
this into Bitcoin.
Let's make a soft fork.
And there's also people who are
not as enthusiastic about it.
And so it's like
no one's opposed
to it-- like, this is a bad
idea, this will break Bitcoin.
But there's varying
levels of let's get this
in, you can do all these
cool things, versus eh,
is this really a priority?
What are we going to use
with it, kind of thing.
OK, any questions about this?
I think we have a quick
break, and then I'll
do OP_RETURN, which
seems unconnected.
But I will show you
how this connects
to these issues we have.
OK, so OP_RETURN, it
was in the problem set.
You basically put this OP code
in the front of your script,
and that flags it as forever
unspendable as an output.
So you shouldn't put much
money into these outputs,
because they are
basically destroyed.
OP_RETURN means you immediately
return from the script
evaluation, and
you return a false.
I think it used to
be return whatever
is on the top of
the stack, which
meant you could just spend
anyone's money by using
OP_RETURN.
So they soft forked that to
say, no, OP_RETURN always
fails instead of
OP_RETURN always
trivially succeeds-- which
means you just put an OP_RETURN
and take anyone's money.
So they figured that
one out pretty quick.
So people use OP_RETURN to
put data into the blockchain.
Why do people do this?
You can't spend it.
You can't do anything
with this data.
But why do people do this?
It's kind of cool, right?
To prove it's there.
You want to put some data in.
And you just want to say,
hey, I thought of this first,
or I'm making a
patent, whatever.
You put data.
People use a lot of OP_RETURN.
What was it?
Like, 10%?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] set.
[INAUDIBLE] the current
[INAUDIBLE] set, if you remove,
or if you don't for
the unspendables,
it would account for about
10% of [INAUDIBLE] data set.
TADGE DRYJA: So
that's a lot of data.
People were using it.
There is a better way.
So what if you wanted to
do a 0 byte OP_RETURN?
It's not quite the same.
Because an OP_RETURN,
everyone can see it.
And in some cases,
you might want that.
You might want to
put an opportunity
so it's publicly visible.
But in most cases, I
don't care about someone's
random OP_RETURN.
Usually, what you're
putting into OP_RETURNs
are, like, hashes.
Because you don't have
much space anyway.
You have, like, 40
bytes or something.
So usually your space
constraint so you
put the hash of some document.
And then someone
can prove, no, look,
I put the document
on the blockchain,
by putting the hash of it.
That's a commitment to
that document itself.
So I show that I had
this data at some time
before this block came out.
That's essentially
what you're proving.
You're proving you knew it
before a certain time, which
is in many cases really useful.
I mean, that's sort of the
whole point of the blockchain,
to prove that you knew
about this transaction
before a future transaction
tries to double spend it.
You want to file a patent,
and I had this idea first--
or prove these things.
But how can we do this
with 0 bytes overhead?
OK, it's not obvious.
You put it in the signature.
And this was not obvious,
and no one thought of this
until a year or two ago.
I think it was Andrew
Poelstra, but I could be wrong.
But I just associate it with
him, because he worked on it.
But I'm not 100% sure.
And he called it pay to contract
hash, which is confusing.
It's not at all the same
as pay to script hash.
as pay to pubkey hash.
But it's called pay to
contract hash, which
makes it really confusing.
Bitcoin has really confusing
names, like script pubkey.
Script pubkey does not have
to have a pubkey in it.
In most cases, it doesn't.
It has a pubkey hash,
or a script hash.
It doesn't have to
have anything in it,
but it's called script pubkey.
And then script sig usually
has signatures, but again,
not always.
And there's all sorts
of confusing names.
Anyway, here's our
new contribution
to confusing names--
pay to contract hash, which is
not really paying to anything.
There doesn't have
to be a contract.
There is a hash involved.
So it's a weird name,
as you can't actually
detect the contract,
you're not paying to it.
But to review, I'm going
to use Schnoor signatures.
This still works in ECDSA.
But ECDSA is weird and
annoying, and it also
makes more sense in
Schnoor signatures,
so I'll explain that.
But it totally works in ECDSA.
The idea of the
Schnoor signatures--
OK, this is my private key.
This is the message
I want to sign.
This is a random sort
of temporary private key
I come up with.
And then this is that
temporary private key
turned into a public key.
Multiply by G to get
the public key version.
And then to verify
the signature,
the verifier multiplies
both sides by G.
So you get s times G. k turns
in R. Little a turns into big A.
This is just the 32-byte
hash, so it stays the same.
So the R and s
are the signature,
and the pub key is A,
and the message is m.
So that's the signing,
or close enough
to the signing that's
used in Bitcoin.
So pay to contract
hash says, OK, I
want to put arbitrary
data into my signature,
in a way that I can
prove it was there.
So here's the normal equation.
Now, what if I redefine k.
Normally, k is just
a random number.
But now I'm going to redefine k.
k is now j.
So j is my new
real random number.
And then I'm going
to add the hash...
There's no G there, shoot.
Anyway, G should not be
there, but it should be there.
Sorry.
So I redefine k as j, which
is an actual random number,
plus the hash of the data
I want to commit to--
and j times G. You get the idea.
That should have been there.
And-- then the signature--
it's still the same equation.
I'm just saying, OK, it's
this new k minus this thing.
And so nobody necessarily
knows that I'm doing this.
If I just tell you
tell you R and s,
the equation still holds.
It's just that k is
a little special.
For anyone else, it looks
like a random number.
It's a random number
plus this other hash--
not times G.
So it's a random
number plus a hash.
Which hashes look
pretty random--
so it's a random number plus
some other random number.
No one's going to tell that
anything's weird about this.
However, it is
unique, in that I've
got this random number plus
the hash of that random number
times G in it, and this
extra data I've put in.
So to verify it, if I
don't tell you about this,
verification looks the same.
What if I do tell
you about it, though?
So normally the sig--
R, s-- pubkey is
A, message is m.
But the signer can
prove that R is not kG--
that there's this other k.
Well, it's k, but there's
something else in R.
I can prove that R is special
after the fact, right?
Everyone knows what R is.
But I can then prove that
something was in R. Also,
never reveal k,
even after the fact.
That will let you figure out
the person's private key.
So the idea is I can
prove that R equals
J plus the hash of
the data in J times G.
Here's where it's a
little confusing, right?
Because this is
already a pubkey,
and you're multiplying
by G again, right?
So it's a little weird?
Anyone can compute this, right?
Because I can say,
hey, you already know
R. I can give you a J and
some data, such that j
plus the hash of this data,
and j itself times G, equals R.
And I can't forge this.
If I try to forge this,
and I say after the fact--
I just made R randomly.
I didn't have any actual data.
And then after the fact, I want
to come up and lie, and say,
I put this data in to this R.
OK, now we need to solve
for J. Because my proof is
going to be J in this data.
So I've got the data I want, and
I want to figure out what J is.
So J is the hash of this data.
And J times G minus
R-- oh, shoot.
That would be the
equation I have to solve,
if I want to falsely prove
that this data went into it.
The problem is
I've got this thing
where it's like, J is defined
in terms of the hash of J.
That's going to be hard, right?
If I'm defining J in
terms of the hash of J,
then I'm stuck, because hash
functions don't let me do that.
So this is actually
kind of cool,
because it's a proof that
there was some extra data that
went in to the random R point,
before the signing happened.
Yeah, it had to be
before the signing
happened, because the
signature has R in it,
and S is a function of R.
And this is cool.
Because if you
don't know about it,
it just looks like a regular
signature with a regular R
value.
But if I tell you about it--
like, yeah, when I
signed that, I actually
put some extra data in here.
So that's kind of
better than OP_RETURN.
There's 0 bytes overhead.
You were going to sign anyway.
So you can put data inside
a signature's R point.
You can even do it with
other people's signatures.
There's no real private
information here.
If I just hand you some
data, it's totally safe.
Hey, here's some data.
OK, here's the J point,
that constructs this,
and the R. It's like,
OK, sounds good.
I can put someone
else's data into this.
You just hand them the data.
They give you the proof,
which in that case is just J.
So it's OP_RETURN
with 0 byte overhead.
This is really cool.
I believe this is being
used for open timestamps
now, as of a few--
I think, right?
AUDIENCE: I wasn't
aware of that.
TADGE DRYJA: I think
they got it in.
I don't know.
But it's also nice-- it's not
like a soft fork or anything.
This is just a fun trick you
can do with your signatures.
So you could do this
today if you wanted,
and then prove to people
later, that, hey, I
put my name into my signature.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
hash, wouldn't proving one
essentially refer to
all in the batch stuff?
TADGE DRYJA: This is direct
replacement for the OP_RETURN.
You commit to the root.
And in their case, this
data is a Merkle root.
And then you can improve.
So you can put a
Merkle root here.
And then I prove that
there's a Merkle root
inside my signature.
And then I also prove a
branch, so that the data
is in the Merkle root, which
is then in the R point-- which
is in the signature, which is in
the block's Merkle tree, which
is in the blockchain.
So you've got, like, four or
five different proofs going on,
but they should all be working.
OK, so this is kind of cool.
Any idea why I was explaining
all this in terms of MAST
and multisig?
These seem totally
unconnected, right?
Any idea?
It took Bitcoin people
like well over a year
to see the, in retrospect,
really obvious connection,
and thing to do with this.
But it took a year or two.
And then Greg posted on the
mailing list in January--
like, hey wait, you can use
this for something else.
And then it was like, oh shoot,
how did no one think of that?
So it's called
taproot, and I don't
know why Greg called it that.
Greg Maxwell, he's a
guy with a big beard,
who works on Bitcoin.
He's super smart and stuff.
And it uses this pay to
contract hash construction.
And it's the same equation,
but it took us a year
or two to figure out
that you could do this.
So the motivation here is
pay to pubkey hash and pay
to script hash look different.
You can tell just
looking at the output,
these are totally
different output scripts.
One of them has
got a pubkey hash.
got a script hash.
Different is bad.
We don't want everything
to look different.
Then, you can sort
of sort things.
You can try to differentiate,
try to track people's coins,
things like that.
You want it to all look uniform,
to make it more anonymous.
So one thing you could
do is just use pay
to script for everything.
You can put a pubkey single--
essentially, 1 of 1 multisig, or
just pay to pubkey hash script
in pay to script hash.
You wouldn't do that.
You'd have that you'd have
the direct pay to pubkey put
into a script hash.
So that like it looks
like a script hash,
and then the script is
public key OP_CHECKSIG.
It's actually not
really any overhead.
I think you actually
save a byte or two.
Nobody does that.
You could.
That might solve like 80% of
what this is trying to solve.
But it's kind of boring and
doesn't use cool math, so
anyway.
OK, the other observation is
that in most cases scripts--
you have these sort of scripts.
And there's a hidden option,
which is, or everyone signs.
So in the case of 2
of 50 multisig-- well,
if all 50 people sign,
that's OK, right?
That's no worse.
So if it's 25 of 50 multisig,
if all 50 people happen to sign,
sure, that's no loss
of security there.
The idea is you use
this pay to script,
pay to contract
hash construction
to merge pay to pubkey hash
and pay to script hash,
so that a single
output can do both.
The idea is you make a key,
J, and J is an actual key.
Like, you have the
private key for it.
It's a regular old pubkey.
And you have a script z.
And instead of sending
either to the script
z, in a pay to script
hash construction,
or to hash this key J
inside the pubkey hash,
you say, I'm going
to compute key C--
which is J plus the hash of my
script, concatenated with J,
times G.
So this is the same
as the thing I just
did with the OP_RETURN
and 0 bytes, right?
And then I send money to it.
And then, what do I do?
I've sent money to this C point.
Can I sign with C's private key?
I know I know a little j.
That's a regular key.
Do I know a little c?
Sure, yeah.
I know that little c is just the
j private key plus this hash.
So if I want to treat it as
a pay to pubkey hash, I just
sign with little c.
I sign my transaction
and I'm good.
Nobody has to know
that I did this.
However, if I want to make
it into pay to script hash,
I reveal the script
z and the subkey J.
And then I put some arguments
on, and then run the script.
So if I don't want to show
that there was a script,
I don't have to.
I just sign with this.
Private key's that.
Nobody knows that there
was a script at all.
So if everyone's using this,
80% of the time that's what
happens.
Maybe there was a
script in there.
Maybe there wasn't.
Can't tell, right?
However, if I want to reveal,
hey, actually this time,
I'm using the script.
So I revealed J and z.
Everyone computes--
OK, well, if I add J
to the hash of z and J
times g, does that equal
c-- the key that is in
the output script itself?
And if it does, cool,
that was a valid proof
that you actually
committed to z.
And now I run the script z.
Any questions about this?
Make sense?
So it's actually pretty simple.
It follows directly from the
proofs, from the contract hash.
And it's really cool because--
oh, P. I thought I
was doing C. Oops.
Anyway.
So what you can
do is you can make
the sum of everyone's keys.
And so in Schnoor
signatures we can do this,
and we can sign
without revealing
each other's private keys.
So you can say,
OK, what I'm going
to do is J is the sum of,
like, 50 different pubkeys.
And then z is that Merkle
tree of 2 of 50 signatures.
So if I want to use 2
of 50, I have to reveal,
and then I have to do the proof.
But if I can get all 50
of 50 people to sign,
they can produce a signature
with private key little C.
So when everyone's
cooperating, you
don't even see that there
was a script involved.
And you can do this
Schnoor signatures.
You cannot do this with ECDSA.
So probably this would
be put into Bitcoin
alongside a Schnoor signature
kind of construction.
This seems useful
because in most
cases, most smart
contracts, most multisig
does have sort of an
all-participants-sign clause.
Even if we don't
code it in right now,
it's generally the case.
Like, 2 of 3 multisig--
well, 3 of 3 is good.
And if you do 3 of 3,
hey, you don't even
see that there was 2 of 3.
And so that preserves privacy.
It saves space.
And most of the time all the
participants can be online.
So that's the same basic
idea as in lightning.
If everyone's co-operative,
you don't even
see that there was
a lightning channel.
You just together broadcast
a transaction with just 2
of 2 multisig.
But in lightning, you do see
that there was 2 of 2 multisig.
So you can sort
of see, oh, it was
either a channel or a multisig.
But in this kind
of construction,
you wouldn't even show that.
You'd say, OK, this is
actually 2 of 2 multisig,
but we can merge them.
Oh, other weird trick--
you can make a public
key, and prove that there
is no known private key.
So what if I only
want this script z,
and there is no set
of everyone signing?
I don't want that
to be a requirement.
What if I only want
the script hash?
I can do that.
Interactively, I can
use someone else's J.
If I'm sending you a script
that involves someone else,
I say, hey, can you
come up with a key J?
I'm going to compute
a key C, that's
J plus the hash of the
script comma J times G.
And then I can prove that
to you after the fact.
And you can say, OK,
well, I know it's my key.
So interactive, I can show
that it's someone else's key.
Non-interactive, I
can just say, look,
I know the pre-image of
the x-coordinate of J.
So basically, I can
prove to you that there's
no way I came up with
this point on the curve
in the normal multiply by G way.
Because that sort of shows that
I came up with the x-coordinate
by just hashing
a random number--
or a non-random number,
if it's the hash of 0,
or if it's the hash of anything.
The idea is I randomly
picked an x-coordinate
on this curve, figured out
what the y-coordinate was,
turned that into
a point, and then
used it in this construction.
If I do that, you
can be pretty sure
that I don't know the
private key for J,
because I didn't compute
it the right way.
Does that make sense?
So you can do that.
That's a way to then
prove to other people
like there is no J. It's
a point on the curve,
but it's a random
point on the curve.
So there's no way
I can sign with c.
I sent the pubkey c.
And I proved to you,
look, C is not a key
that anyone can sign with.
However, there is a point
J, and there's a script z,
and you can execute the script.
So that's useful in
many cases, where
you want to prove to
people that, look,
there is no key here.
It's just a script.
And then everyone will find
out later when you spend it.
But they don't have to
know that there was no key.
They just know that the
script got executed.
So that's a nice sort of
patch, where you can default.
If there's any use cases where
in the current script hash
you want that exact
same functionality
and you don't want
this new functionality,
you can sort of get
rid of it this way.
AUDIENCE: So the
idea of [INAUDIBLE]
is that you are trying to
make your special transaction
scripts not stand
out [INAUDIBLE]..
The fear is that people will
see those and not put them
into blocks, or not
[INAUDIBLE] them,
or discriminate against them?
TADGE DRYJA: Maybe a little.
But it's more that--
let's say I have
my wallet software,
and it always uses to
P2WSH, P2SH, or something.
Then I can say, oh, I bet
this is the same person.
I can try to track
who is spending them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, a big
part of it is privacy.
Maybe they're discriminated
against them like miners.
Probably, the miners don't care.
But it's more like if
everyone's using software
that can create
similar transactions,
then it becomes much harder
to tell people apart,
and it has more privacy
for the transactions.
AUDIENCE: Then this one,
you're putting in a script
that can anybody can
potentially execute it,
but they don't
know that they can?
TADGE DRYJA: They need
to know both the script
and J, which is not
obvious from C. C
is the only thing you see on
the blockchain, in the output.
And so they just
said, it's a key--
probably, someone
knows the private key.
Maybe there's some weird
thing like this going on.
You don't have to
use this, right?
And then, yeah, so they
won't know what J or z are.
AUDIENCE: Still
you're [INAUDIBLE]..
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
You can publicly publish
it, if you want--
and tell everyone in
the world, hey, this C
is actually this J
plus this script z.
They still can't spend it.
That can be public,
even beforehand.
And then they see, oh,
there's a script and a key.
And you can also, say,
sign something, and prove
that you know the private
key for J. So you can say,
I can prove that
I'm not doing this--
there is no J kind of thing.
So you can prove all those
things, but you don't need to.
For normal usage, you just
send a key C, spend from key C.
You're done.
And if you want to
spend from the script z,
you just provide J, the script
, and then execute the script.
So it's nice.
And you might have had a script,
and then you didn't use it,
so you didn't reveal
that there was a script.
So it helps with privacy.
It helps with efficiency
in many cases,
because if you don't need to
use a script, you don't have to.
So in a lot of cases you
say, all three of the 2 of 3
multisigs are on board, so let's
use C instead of the script z.
So it's pretty cool.
OK, so questions about this?
Go to the next crazy thing.
Little notes about
taproot-- anyone
can make a key and
script and send to it.
Only the pubkeys are needed.
So if I want to send to
something that's 3 of 3--
Alice, Bob, and Carol
added all together--
or 2 of the 3 of Alice,
and Bob, and Carol--
I don't have to even ask
Alice, Bob, and Carol.
If I know they're
public keys, I can just
compute all this myself,
and send money to them.
And I can compute any
construction I want.
I can make it 1 of 3.
I know Alice, Bob, and
Carol's public keys.
And I can say, hey
Alice, Bob, and Carol,
I'm giving you all money,
and you can fight over it--
or you can cooperate.
Like, any of you get it.
And so the idea is 1 of 3
multisig script goes into here,
and then 3 of 3 is here.
So if you cooperate, you
save a little bit of space,
and the fees are smaller.
But if you don't cooperate, any
of you can grab it immediately.
I don't know how useful that
is, but you could do this.
You don't need knowledge
of any private keys
to construct C. Only
the pubkeys are needed.
That's actually really nice,
because you're creating.
So the same is currently
the case in Bitcoin.
If you're creating an
output script, like pay
to pubkey hash,
pay to script hash,
there's no private keys
involved in that process.
You just tell everyone.
OK, which differs, and is
the important distinction
between the next cool
thing, which is graftroot--
also Greg Maxwell, like a
week or two after taproot.
They're not actually
that similar.
But it was like, wait--
people were sort of
talking about it.
So the idea is allow
a lot of scripts
with a proof that goes up
in size with 0 of 1-- aka
it doesn't go up in size.
So the Merkle
proofs-- the MAST--
go in log n.
So if you've got a
million different scripts,
you're going to take
something like 20 hashes
or whatever to prove that.
What's a proof that grows in
0 of 1 of the number of things
being proven?
It's actually not--
it's kind of obvious.
Like, I want to prove
something, and the proof size
does not change regardless of
how many things I am proving.
Well, it's just a signature.
If I make a million signatures,
they're all the same size.
So I could, instead of
making a Merkle route,
I just have all
these little leaves.
And I just sign them all.
And a leaf with a
signature is just as good.
So the idea is this
is called graftroot.
It's similar to taproot in that
it's got sort of two execution
paths.
You send to a key C, and there's
two ways to spend from it.
So you can use the
regular pay to pubkey hash
mode, where you're
just spending from C.
You just sign with key
C, your transaction--
same as in taproot, same as
in regular Bitcoin right now.
That's the easy one.
The script version
is I show a script s,
and a signature from
key C on the message
s, and then I
execute that script.
So this is kind of cool, right?
You say, look, I'm sending
you a key, and either that key
itself signs or that
key endorses a script
to be executed.
And I can make as many
of these as I want.
So if I want 1,000
different scripts,
it's not like I have to prove
inclusion in the three--
that's going to be height 22,
or height 12, or whatever--
I just have a signature,
saying, OK, key C
signed this to a 50 multisig.
Key C also signed the
other two of 50 multisig.
So the one that
I'm actually using,
I just provide the proof.
The proof of inclusion
is just a signature.
Questions about this?
Makes sense?
Kind of weird?
It works.
The real problem is there
is this key C, right?
So there's this sort of root key
that controls the whole thing.
The idea is key C endorses
all the different leaves.
So in the case of
MAST you've got,
let's say, four different
scripts that can execute.
All four of those are committed
to by the Merkle root.
In the case of
graftroot, let's say
you have four different scripts.
C signs all four of
those different scripts.
The thing is, C can
sign 10 scripts.
C has got total control
over this output.
Whereas before,
in the MAST idea,
it can be different people.
It could be Alice and Bob, Carol
and Dave, Edna and Gertrude--
I don't know.
And they might not be friends.
No single entity there
has full control.
So the idea of
this is, well, you
can combine a whole
bunch of people.
The key C is
essentially everyone,
and they all have to sign off on
all the different scripts that
could happen, and
then distribute
those signatures on those
scripts, which are proofs.
OK, basic idea make sense?
This one's a little weirder.
In this one there is a way to
prove that there is no key C.
So that's to sort of
say, look, it's only
going to be this
script, and no one's
going to sign in the normal
just the key signs method.
There's also a way
to do that here.
It's much less useful, though,
because what you essentially do
is you start with your
script, and then you
compute a signature on it--
but you also prove that
there was no private key that
made the signature.
You have time.
It's actually really fun.
What you do is--
normally you say, OK, S equals
k minus the hash of my message
and R times point a.
What if I want to prove
to you that there is no a?
SG equals R minus the hash
of message R times pubkey A.
I want to prove that I do
not know that private key,
and nobody knows it.
Actually, I have to both.
I say, OK, I know the
pre-image of the x-coordinate.
Same with R. Wait,
can I do this?
I forget how this
is going to work.
Anyway, basically what I do is
I compute A public key randomly.
Or no, I first get the
message I want to sign.
I make a random R, and I
show that it's random--
I know the pre-image of its
coordinates, or something.
I can prove that I
didn't construct this.
I don't know the private key.
And then I solve for
A and S, essentially.
So I can show, look,
I've got a signature,
but I can prove
that no one signed.
I think I make a
random s, and then I
solve for big A. I make a random
s, multiply by G, solve for A.
So A divided by hash of m, R--
wait, I can't do that, can I?
Yeah, I can.
This is [INAUDIBLE.]
Equals R minus SG.
I come up with a random
R, put it in here,
come up with the message I want
to sign, and then solve for A.
So I can do that,
and I can prove
that there was no
real A, because
of the way I constructed it.
I know weird things
about R and A.
And so I can show that this
is not a real signature.
However, in this case,
it's not that useful.
In the case of
taproot, it's useful,
because I might want to
prove to people, look,
this is just a script.
There is no key.
In this case, I
can still do that.
I can say, there's
just a script.
There is no key.
But then I can only do it once.
The whole idea of
graftroot is I can
have a million
different scripts, that
are all going into one key.
OK, so the problem is the root
key must sign every script.
And now you need to use private
keys to create an address.
That's not great, right?
It's maybe OK, but you
haven't had to do that before.
So now we have to sign
off on every script
that we're endorsing, in
order to compute an address.
You can do this after
the fact, though.
So that's kind of the
interesting thing about this,
is you can say, OK, I'm
sending the key C-- which
is this root key, that's
all 50 participants.
And then after the
fact-- after it's
gone been confirmed in
the blockchain-- those 50
participants can say, actually,
you know what, 2 of 50 is good.
We're not suspending
the money right now.
But we're all agreeing
that, yeah, any two of us
can spend this money later.
And so they all get together,
and all 50 sign with the root
key C all the different
scripts-- those 1,225 scripts--
and then hand those
signatures out
to the respective
people who would be
interested in that signature.
So, oh, Alice and Bob, if
you want to spend the money,
we all made a signature
endorsing your 2 of 2,
2 of 50--
your two keys.
And Bob and Carol, if you
two want to spend the money,
we've made a script that's
endorsed by us saying,
your two keys can spend it.
It's really cool.
The overhead is one signature.
So you can have that like
100 trillion different--
50 choose 25, which
is 100 trillion.
Well, you've got to
sign 100 trillion times,
but when you spend
from it, it's small.
It's an extra 33
bytes of overhead.
Yeah, the overhead
is just a signature.
So you say, OK, here's key C.
Here's a signature from it.
Here's the script, to endorse
the script being executed.
It's not actually 64 bytes.
You can get the
overhead into 33 bytes,
because you can aggregate the
S values of the signature.
I'll talk about
this on Wednesday.
I don't think I actually
came up with this,
but Greg cites me
on it, and it's
like, I guess no
one thought of this.
But there's a non-interactive
partial aggregation
of these things,
which I was really
hoping would get
into Bitcoin itself,
but I think it's too slow.
But in this case it's not that
slow, so people are like, yeah,
we'll use it here.
So this is kind of cool,
because it's simple.
It's just more scripts
can be added any time.
It's all one scaling.
So if you have it a
million different scripts,
proving one of them takes 32
bytes, or 33, or something.
C can be a threshold signature
of many different parties.
The signature can be aggregated
within the transaction.
The downside is this interactive
setup, where you can't just
take Alice, and Bob,
and Carol's key,
and send to a graftroot
2 of 3 multisig.
Alice, and Bob, and Carol
need to sign something.
In some cases
that's no big deal.
In some cases, you're connected
to them over the internet,
and all the participants
are cooperating.
Sure, we'll sign.
We'll create addresses.
Or we'll pre-sign all sorts of
different addresses beforehand.
Doable, but sometimes you don't
want this interactive setup.
Sometimes I want
to be able to send
to participants of my choosing,
without their cooperation.
Really, usually for
sending people money,
they're OK with it, right?
But sometimes you don't
want them to be online.
So put this all together.
The goal for this, and I think
the way it's going to work
in Bitcoin-- but this
is still research--
you have a unified
output script.
So let's say it's a
templated with OP_5.
And you say, OK, OP_5, pubkey.
Now, when I want to spend to
it, I have a bunch of options.
To spend, I can just put
a signature on the stack.
And then the program says,
oh, there's a signature.
Let me check if the signature
matches the public key--
you know, this pubkey.
And if it does, cool,
the money moves.
That's pay to pubkey hash
mode, except it's not hashed.
Another thing I could do
is provide a point J--
a script-- and a series of
arguments for the script.
And that's taproot.
I verify that J plus the hash
of J in the script times G
is equal to that pubkey, and
then I execute that script.
Another way to do it
is if I've got this--
I've got C, which
is also just a point
and a signature on the script--
and then a script, and a bunch
of arguments, then I say,
oh, this is graftroot.
I'll verify this
signature on this script,
and then execute
with these arguments.
So it would be cool if
you could do it just based
on the number of items pushed.
But you might want to put
like a flag or something here,
to distinguish
between these two.
And with this, if
there's just one element,
you can just quickly say,
OK, it's pay to pubkey.
But to distinguish
between these two
there might be weird
edge cases, where
it's like, well,
one of the arguments
could also look like a
script, and annoying things.
So you might put some, like,
flag byte But anyway, it's
kind of nice, in that when
you send to an output,
you send to an address, all
the addresses look the same.
They just look like
public keys, but they
could be any of these
things, and you only
find out after the fact.
And not only that--
you could have
the same key have a taproot
and also have a graftroot.
So there could be an address.
And I've gotten my wallet.
Well, there's three different
ways I can spend this.
I can spend this with everyone--
all 50 people-- signing.
Or I can spend it
with a single script
that's been endorsed this
way, that's got priority.
And then I can also
spend it with one
of the millions of scripts that
have been endorsed this way.
So I can use all three.
This is a little
bit more efficient,
because you're just revealing
the script and a point.
This one, you have to reveal.
Oh no, wait, sorry,
this is wrong.
There's no C. You already
know C. It's still
a little more efficient.
Yeah, there's no C there.
You already know C. You just
put the signature on the script.
Yeah, OK, so that's [INAUDIBLE]
OK, so this is
graftroot, taproot.
And then, also, part of
the script can be masked.
You can have a masked OP code.
You can combine all these
things in crazy ways,
and have like really
powerful scripting that way.
So when this stuff was
proposed, the argument was,
hey, I don't want to
spend to a public key.
I want to spend to
a public key hash.
Because quantum
computers are coming.
And when the quantum computers
come, if you know my pubkey,
you can just calculate
my private key,
and take all my money.
But if you only know
my public key hash,
quantum computer
doesn't help you there.
You're not going to be able to
compute the pre-image of a hash
with a quantum computer.
All of those
statements are true,
except in practice it's dumb.
Because if there's a
quantum computer that
can compute your private
key from your public key,
the only time
using pubkey hashes
will help you is if somehow
that quantum computer takes
a really long time to
compute your private key.
Because if it only takes
them a minute to compute it,
well, you have to reveal your
public key to spend your money.
And then the attacker, who has
this nifty quantum computer,
can just say, oh,
that's his public key.
I just saw it.
And he signed.
And using his public key, I
just compute his private key,
sign a different message,
and broadcast it.
And maybe I attach a higher fee.
Because I don't care,
it's not my money.
And the miners are
like, well, there's
two different transactions--
one sending over here,
one sending over here.
This one has a much higher fee.
I'll use this one.
And the attacker with
the quantum computer
still takes all your money.
They can't take it at rest.
They have to wait for you to
try to spend it and take it.
But you could say,
OK, well actually,
I'm doing OP_5, pubkey hash.
And then for this, I have
to reveal pubkey signature.
For this, I reveal j
component of pubkey script.
For this, I reveal
C and the sig.
But it's kind of ugly.
It wastes space,
and in most cases
doesn't provide a
lot of protection.
So there's hopefully better
ways to deal with this.
One thing that I have
sort of been joking about,
but would be kind of fun
to put it into [INAUDIBLE]..
You can actually use
taproot to commit
to a Lamport-like
hash-based pubkey.
So in taproot this is
actually quantum secure.
I hesitate to advertise this.
But it is a commitment that the
quantum computer cannot forge.
Where was I saying
the J equals hash of--
yeah, this thing is still a
problem for a quantum computer.
I want to compute
a J such that J
equals this hash times G minus
R. And J is in there as well.
Even with a quantum
computer, maybe I can compute
an arbitrary J and find its
discrete lock-- you know,
find the private key--
but it's still not going
to satisfy this equation.
So I can't after the fact
find a script and a J
to compute this C. So that
is safe, even if a quantum
computer exists,
because that's based
on the security
the hash function.
So that's kind of an
interesting little tidbit--
like, hey, this taproot
construction is hash based.
Quantum computer appears, and
we say, look, we no longer allow
C. We no longer allow
the normal spend, where
you sign with key C,
because signatures--
all this elliptic curve
stuff, it's broken.
However, we do
allow you to prove
that there was a script
z committed to in C.
And then maybe this script has
like a quantum-safe signature
in it, and then we can use that.
What's nice about that is you
can start using it sooner,
and without the overhead of
all the extra space taken
by the quantum
signature, because it's
sort of a backup plan.
It's like, well,
normally I'm just
signing with C, because I know
this is just my regular key--
and I do this.
But worst-case scenario,
if a quantum computer
appears in 10 years, I've
got my other backup key here.
So that's kind of a cool thing.
I don't know how useful
it is in practice.
So yeah, you've got
all these three things.
The other thing about this is--
I don't know, big
multisig is one use case.
It seems really
powerful, and like, hey,
I can make these millions
of different scripts,
and Merkle trees of
different scripts,
and taproot and graftroot.
Not a ton of really good
real world use cases, though,
I think that would
motivate it a lot more.
Because a lot of the hesitation
from people working on Bitcoin
is like, OK, this
is really cool,
but what are we
going to do with it?
As I'll talk about on
Wednesday, multisig itself
is not the best motivation.
Because once we have
Schnoor signatures
and aggregate signatures there's
direct ways to do multisig,
that are actually more
privacy preserving
and more space preserving.
So we need to use cases.
And that's one of the
debates-- like, OK,
what do we do with this?
This is kind of cool.
You can make all sorts
of weird smart contracts,
but what are some
real-world use cases?
There's also sort of argument--
OK, MAST versus
graftroot versus both.
Well, if you have graftroot, do
you really need MAST anymore?
Instead of this big
Merkle tree, you just
have the signatures
endorsing the leaves.
So it sort of seems
better scalability there.
But graftroot is interactive,
so maybe you still want MAST.
Maybe you have both.
There's all sorts
of debate on this.
And so in practice that may mean
that since people are arguing
next year, the year after, it's
hard to get everyone on board
to do stuff.
There is code, though.
Some things have code.
A lot of it's sort of
obvious enough, that like,
yeah, graftroot makes sense.
Just have them sign.
The taproot construction
there's code for.
But it's not all put together.
There's no spec for
all these things.
So if people are interested in
this stuff, start coding it.
Start trying it out.
Come up with cool
use cases, and maybe
push for one thing
or another to get in.
There's a full request open
in Bitcoin right now for MAST.
I know some people
are really into it,
and other people are
like, uh, I don't know.
Also, how to implement
MAST exactly.
So this is still
research kind of level,
but it seems that
they're usable,
and it may improve
smart-contract functionality.
So cool stuff here.
Any questions about this?
All right, cool.
So I'll do office
hours tomorrow at 4:00.
We can talk about
projects and stuff.
And the next class
on Wednesday will
be even more crazy
elliptic curve stuff
about aggregate signatures,
Schnoor signatures,
multi signatures, threshold
signatures, things like that.
And also, privacy--
I'm going to focus on
the signature part.
I also put privacy and CoinJoin
in there, which is related,
but might be squished
towards the end
if I don't have a ton of time.